all right and here we are as tradition
dictates i gave you my list of my top 10
favorite movies of 2021. now here are
the least favorites the top 10 worst
though to be fair in a world where i
didn't see as many movies in 2021 as i
usually see there were quite a few
movies i was like nope
don't want to see it don't need to see
it looks horrible gonna pass keeping
your job which is your hobby from
feeling like work that is the trick my
friends that's the balancing act so this
list is more or less top 10
disappointing movies of 2021 yeah there
are a couple of champs on here that's
for sure but for the most part this
video could be called top 10
disappointing moves at 2021 keep that in
mind why is it not called disappointing
why is it still called worse people
don't look for disappointing movies of
2021 they look for worst don't hate the
player hate the game but to get us
started label out not sponsored
and what is that a finger and a half
sure that's enough for the video also
seeing the cop why do some people think
this is apple juice you think i'm buying
18-year single malt just to not drink it
to swap it out for apple juice think
about my [ __ ] mind i said remarkably
smooth
nice citrusy aftertaste i suggest now we
have that which
might make things better so let's get on
with the list the top 10 disappointing
movies of 2021
starting out this list venom let there
be carnage i wanted to love venom let
there be carnage i always loved venom
and carnage but this movie for venom was
a backstep the first venom movie had
this weird buddy cop buddy parasite
dynamic and that worked it was
unexpected for the first venom movie but
okay because the first venom movie left
off with venom being the lethal
protector but in this movie they were
like still pg-13 so we can't have him be
the lethal protector so we'll just do
more of what we did in the first venom
movie venom and carnage fighting that
was cool but they didn't know how to
make a compelling movie built around
that they didn't know how to engage you
leading up to that fight it was just
it happened left off with an interesting
post-credits scene though which
doesn't matter i guess anyhow on a
number nine number nine
well i guess cruella didn't disappoint
me because i've never really given a
[ __ ] about the character of cruella
deville i just haven't cared but i
wasted my time with this movie so okay
if you're gonna take a heinous shitty
villain who skins dogs and wears their
coats at least you can make an
interesting movie they didn't if this
movie was called anything else if it was
another character other than cruella
deville maybe but as it stands this is a
weird cruella de ville movie starring
cruella deville that doesn't feel like
cruella de vil i hope disney has it out
of their system at this point i hope to
like hey we tried making villains
sympathetic characters and protagonists
um not working so we're just gonna make
villains villains and heroes heroes and
all right that was this phase of our
lives i doubt it it's just it's this low
on the list because like i said there's
i really had nothing invested in the
character cruella deville that said i
was just mostly bored for this movie i
didn't care it happened that's the
feeling of a lot of movies on this list
well that happened
next
now black widow is a character i cared
about and that was a character a lot of
people were saying hey give black widow
the standalone movie what's up and
marvel was like no and then marvel was
like oh [ __ ] people really liked wonder
woman i guess there's money to be made i
mean yes how progressive are we
that we sat on it until dc made money
off of it too little too late at this
point there would have been stakes if
the movie came out before black would
have you know
died i mean i'm a chronic procrastinator
myself i'm not going to procrastinate
for half a decade not doing something
that's a bit much at least it had
taskmaster
a villain that didn't feel anything like
taskmaster and it's only marvel studios
fault that is too little too late they
didn't have the faith in the character
they should have had and really come to
think of it a lot of movies on this list
encapsulate the problem i have with
hollywood this is the problem i have
with the mcu it's the hubris of vomiting
out this movie with a character in it
years after it should have come out and
they were like yeah people will watch it
it's an mcu movie after all
[Laughter]
number seven
snake ice is so [ __ ] cool at least
his character is is movie standalone i
mean i'm not a huge fan of the
live-action gi joe movies that came
before snake guys i mean the second one
much better than the first one but ray
park as snake eyes completely felt like
snake eyes if for nothing else they
nailed snake eyes in the movies actually
snake eyes and storm shadow this was
just a movie with a guy in it who ended
up being snake guys
never felt like a snake eyes movie the
worst part is the marketing they do for
things like this the marketing for the
snake ice movie was like snake guys here
he is in his suit it's like that's the
last shot of the movie it's kind of dick
total setup for some new gi joe universe
that is probably never gonna happen
because the movie just fell flat for
fans i have heard it said that the best
gi joe movie is actually the van damme
street fighter movies the best gi joe
movie we've ever gotten
and i do agree
number six
next up the matrix regurgitations i
don't i just did a video on this it did
the review and the spoiler video i don't
need to do another video on it i feel
like i can just be like yeah it's on the
list next i do have my fingers crossed
for this movie like if i find out down
the road that this movie is some sort of
middle finger troll act to basically
blast warner brothers from making lana
wachowski do this movie nothing but
respect that is grade a top tier troll
move and i salute you if that's the case
that said even if that is the case as it
stands as a movie for my enjoyment it
absolutely fell flat i recently watched
the matrix reloaded and revolutions
after watching
resurrections i forgot for a second
that's how memorable this movie is but i
watched the other matrix sequels after
watching this they are decidedly
absolutely better than resurrection it
just feels like that basic hollywood
sequel that's two decades after the
other sequels where the other sequels
wrapped up the story and it was like all
right well let's just make another one
and it feels forced 100 this this is
where i'm like yep this list is they're
the top 10 disappointments of the year
number five
next up now this is the movie i'm gonna
set it up a little bit there was a
review i did after this movie and i was
like well i gave it a good time if
you're drunk whatever that other movie
was and i said something like well
sometimes it doesn't make it better as i
recently found out such is the case with
mortal kombat i gave this movie a good
time if you're drunk because i was like
hey get the drinks flowing maybe it's a
better time then my friend visited from
out of town we were both huge mortal
kombat fans back in the day childhood
friend i was like hey let's watch the
new mortal kombat get the drinks flowing
all we did was talk [ __ ] about this
movie the entire time it was so much
worse with the drinks flowing though it
was like well that is a very flawed
rating that i came up with
don't know what to do about that
but that is the way i mean you could
pluck elements out of this movie and say
that's deserving of another movie kano
sub-zero scorpion
the three minutes of screen time
scorpion had but i left when i said that
in my review i was like well i want to
see a sequel just done better i'm like
yeah you want to see a good mortal
kombat movie don't we all cheers there
jeremy for your no [ __ ] statement it
didn't get better with alcohol my
friends it got worse
disappointment 100
number four
carrying on the tradition of video game
movies we have the new resident evil
what's it called resident evil welcome
to raccoon city yeah this movie i
remember when i saw the trailer and it
was like coming only to theaters it was
like theater
well i couldn't have called that from
how that one looked i thought it was
gonna be one of those fathom events you
know one of those streaming things in
movie theaters that's due for plays and
musicals or maybe it was like hey here's
a made-for-tv movie but it's resident
evil fathom event coming to you it
wasn't it was 100 here is a movie in
movie theaters that feels like made for
tv which is funny because i feel like
there's this whole generation that's
coming up that they're not gonna know
what made for tv means you know they're
gonna be like you mean like netflix like
streaming service no made for tv it was
so much worse come on amazon look for
one of those hallmark movies and watch
that now think of that
but theatrical and that's what the new
resident evil felt like to me
number three
thunder force remember thunder force
right hopefully not a lot of people do
unlike that dude who was floating in
mary poppins i love to laugh when a
movie that's supposed to make me laugh
doesn't make me laugh it just makes me
sad there is something to be said about
a comedy
that's bad you know it just feels worse
than an action movie that's bad
or a drama that's bad to see comedy fall
so flat in a premise that should be a
layup a superhero comedy we've had them
before now that superheroes are bigger
than ever i feel like it would you'd
have more content to pull from super
tammy as i call it it's what it feels
like i feel like that's pretty accurate
number two
[Music]
home sweet home alone this is one of
those movies i saw so much chatter about
this and that is the times this is the
times we live in there there was a time
when straight to video home alone movies
got zero chatter might as well have
never even heard that they existed i
didn't know they existed they just went
under the radar into oblivion but now
disney plus streaming service and i
heard about home sweet home alone i was
like i gotta see this [ __ ] for myself
and i was i was simultaneously
disappointed also not disappointed it
lived up to every horrid expectation i
had from the online chatter but also
killed me on the inside another horrid
attempt by blind ass hollywood thinking
hey we know what makes money we know
what fans want but you don't cause
you're heartless soulless bastards you
don't know what it is to love a
franchise or characters or a movie you
just say hey will enough people stream
this piece of [ __ ] online to make our
money back he was hoping for flipping a
coin but suppose you throw a coin enough
times
suppose one day it lands on its edge
number one
you know
after number one came out in theaters i
was promised an influx of lola bunny
rule 34 content which i have not seen
that's not why the new space gem made
the list not why it made number one
doesn't help its case there are quite a
few movies on this list that epitomize
that which is wrong with hollywood the
soulless lifeless uninspired husks
running at 24 frames a second but space
jam 2
what was it called i'm going to call it
space jam 2. so i don't give two shits
take something nostalgic from the past
check it was a basketball game before
now it's a basketball game but video
game this is like cell phone game
basketball rules where it wasn't
actually basketball you had looney tunes
characters last time now there's a
plethora of warner brothers characters
this time them all can be found
streaming now on hbo max go and make
that a triple check just felt like the
longest commercial the longest ad you've
ever seen in this digital age of online
entertainment that's saying something
also the makeup and making the
background characters look like these
notable characters from warner brothers
ip was terrible they looked worse than
snl sketches lebron's acting
if you've ever had that argument with
your friends you know that hollywood
isn't even trying any more argument your
friends told you hey you're being harsh
maybe you're just being grumpy show them
the new space jam it's all the visual
aid you need to hammer that point home
other movies on this list had [ __ ] i
hated but space jam 2 had everything i
hated from those movies but like the ex
plus alpha edition for all those reasons
is why you made number one new space jam
movie cheers
to everyone out there who had to watch
you
and with the close of this video comes
the close of another year the year 2021
another year in which all of you
kept my channel going for another year
and i want to thank you for that i
sincerely mean that i want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart i don't want
you to think that i take you all for
granted and your support for my channel
what it does for my life and the people
around me it can get a little real with
you uh if you don't like heavy
conversations i do apologize but real is
real so here we go this past year last
summer my dad had a heart attack luckily
someone was with him who called 9-1-1
right when it happened but his heart and
respiratory function stopped right when
the ambulance showed up the timing of it
was
it was a scary thing it really was it's
actually the reason my review for old
went up a little late because i was
editing my review got the phone call
went to the hospital long medical
explanations
later gonna bypass a lot of it one
chemically induced coma and bypass
surgery later he's been staying with me
for the past few months ever since it
happened he stayed with me because i had
the spare bedroom that he could stay in
and i had the schedule that i could
essentially work around him him needing
my help as he needed it when he was
healing all that is to say your support
in supporting my channel and supporting
my life helped my dad in this situation
this past year so we both thank you all
thank you very much also hug your loved
ones life moves fast it comes at you
fast
and you just never know i didn't we got
lucky with my dad and i appreciate the
extra time we have there are no
guarantees so definitely make that phone
call tell your loved ones you love them
anyhow i keep my private life private on
my channel i don't tell you the workings
of the personal life and the family
dynamic generally speaking but i felt
you all deserved a huge hug a huge thank
you and he's been smoke free for the
past five months i think it's five
months too late to do math right now but
dad if you're watching five months no
cigarette very proud of you good job all
right so as this year 2021 comes to a
close you gotta have your disappointing
list you know what is it ten seven five
fewer than that congratulations
you skipped past garbage i envy what are
the movies that fell flat or otherwise
disappointed you this past year whatever
they are comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you